and now the gentlemen we have to thank
for all the great music tonight Academy
award-winning conductor of our academy
award Orchestra mr. bill Conti and then
from singing in the rain to the
Unsinkable Molly Brown to mother please
welcome Debbie Reynolds
thank you thank you before we get to the
nominees I'm not gonna lie to you I was
a little disappointed by not being
nominated myself but what I did was I I
took to my bed for two weeks and then I
discovered this wonderful support group
called the non nominees anonymous huh oh
nana noms
well maybe not maybe not so anonymous
Courtney Love Madonna
Barbra Streisand and these wonderfully
generous gifted and complicated women
took me in and nominated me as their
friend so it is to them that I would
like to express my gratitude for helping
me out of my deep funk into the shallow
one now to the teleprompter home the
precious gift of laughter film comedy
provides
the the provide that who wrote this
drivel I would like to meet the writers
who wrote this drivel is there a writer
on premise is there a writer in the
house I would like to find out there
what what is it mama can we I can't say
this drivel well it's my first year
writing drivel I was really just
following house lead could somebody get
half how Cantor or Baz or Bruce well
honey but look we'll just cut it how
good the show could be shorter anyway
well you couldn't
the best the best nominees for best
score in the musical or comedy are
Rachel Portman for Emma Marc Shaiman for
the First Wives Club Alan Menken and
Stephen Schwartz for Hunchback of Notre
Dom Randy Newman for James and the Giant
Peach Hans Zimmer for the preacher's
wife
the Oscar goes to and the Oscar goes to
Rachel Portman for Emma
I would like to thank Doug McGrath who's
a wonderful person to work with the
producers of Emma Harvey Weinstein and
everyone at Miramax my agents Richard
and Lynn my wonderful parents my husband
family friends and Philip for all their
support and lastly all the musicians and
team of people back in England who work
with me on Emma
thank you
please welcome a memorable performer on
previous Oscar shows actor dancer
Gregory Hines
we're running a bit long so let's get
right to it for best achievement in
dramatic scoring the nominees are
Gabriel Yared for the English Patient
Patrick Doyle for Hamlet Elliot
Goldenthal for Michael Collins
David Hershberger for Shine and John
Williams for sleepers and the Oscar goes
to
Gabriel Yared for the English Patient
I'm very grateful to the Academy and
very honored to be here I would like to
thank the orchestra martin-in-the-fields
my conductor Walter Murch again and my
editors Bob Randall and Ling Ling and
indicate this award to my wife thank you